real Rejects real Rejects relate to start the
story they were way later weeks after the premiere
after so many patrons uh or super sexy rejects
have been requesting this I was like all right
okay yeah let's do this we're going to churn
out our reactions for one of the most popular
Netflix series apparently Wednesday I'm excited
to see it only because people keep harassing us at
our patreon page and that harassment has paid off
John how are you I am excited I'm looking forward
to this how are you good good you're you're Adam
Sandler guy aren't you I have an Addams Family Guy
I'm an Adam's Family Guy he said it ladies and
gentlemen you know what to do you got to leave
a like that's the first request that we have
for you guys helps out the video doesn't take
too much effort on your own please go ahead and
do it also uh subscribe click that notification
Bell because yeah we got to get through all eight
of these episodes you want to get notified when
our reaction is up as always full length rash
watch along as we sync up with your own copy
are available for a super sexy Rejects at our
patreon page and over there we cover some shows
exclusively uh at the same tier with reaction
highlights and watch alongs included thank you
to all of our patrons who have helped us have a
very successful year at the reject Nation let's
see what all the hype is about I haven't seen
anything about this let's see what's going on
foreign I'm not sure whose Twisted idea it was
to put hundreds of adolescents in underfunded
schools run by people whose dreams were crushed
years ago this guy good morbid point it feels
like an 80s high school movie man just as colorful
Pugsley I want names don't know who they were it
happened so fast hugsley emotion equals weakness
pull yourself together smack him
psychic abilities I'm not about to confess
to my brother that I've recently been
plagued by visions I feel like electroshock
therapy but without dissatisfying afterburn
what are you gonna do what
I do best murder [Music]
she's got that walk down they
had to be swimmers didn't they
the only person who gets
to torture my brother is me
oh no oh God
oh that is cruel oh yeah
go get him oh yeah [Music]
can I already feel it get the main guy
oh
yeah what an opening contain your Glee
oh this is gonna be fun yeah guest
starring them oh Danny Elfman did the music
hey Tim Burton directed it huh
[Music] Lurch
oh my goodness I promise you my little Piper
you will love Nevermore I have no interest in
following in your footsteps becoming captain of
the fencing team Queen of the dark prom president
of the Scion Society say on society you'll learn
about emotion that boy's family was going to file
attempted murder charges how would that have
looked on your record terrible pretty great
everyone would know I failed to get the job
done eyes of the prize Wednesday [Laughter]
some kind of not exactly Hogwarts School
but kind of it runs right past Nevermore
the school for outcasts that's a polite way of
putting it oh so Nevermore is kind of
like Xavier School basically [Music]
God damn werewolves there's been murder and
someone's responsible Wednesday is certainly
a unique name there she is did your mother
tell you we were roommates back in the day
and you graduated with your
sanity intact impressive
ouch I've assigned you to your mother's old
dorm Ophelia Hall ah Ophelia is the one who
killed herself after being driven
mad by her family Shakespeare fan
yep welcome to Ophelia Hall not a hugger
alert you to color what happens to you
I break out into hives and then the flesh peels
off my bones yikes perfect opposite for Wednesday
welcome to the quad definitely looks a bit like
Hogwarts or the things AKA vampires check that
bunch of Knuckleheads are first AKA werewolves
werewolves I'm assuming scales are sirens
you catch on quick and Batgirl Bianca Barclay
is the closest thing Nevermore has to loyalty
oh my God cool she's today a resident tortured
artist Xavier Thorpe but they broke up the
beginning of the semester resident tortured she
totally chowed down on that kid she murdered you
better watch your back hey Jax this is my new
roommate Wednesday is he a Medusa here I'm black
and white like a living Instagram filter ignore
him Gorgon spent way too much time getting stoned
stoned I know you should really
get on Insta Snapchat and tick tock
I find social media to be a soul-sucking
void of meaningless affirmation thank
you yes follow me at the Greg album yes
queen look at you my little death trap
any plans you have of running away and right
now I will escape this educational penitentiary
I got you a little
what's up w and it's made of obsidian
which Aztec priest used conservations
ah and it'll help you solve some motives I
am not you mother I will never fall in love
or be a housewife or have a family
or accept this direct metaphor for
that you're more like than you realize
Wednesday my little scorpion won't be alone
let's do this what the hell did you do to my room
dividing our room equally that's some great
production design silence would be appreciated
this is my riding time your writing time
with the loudest machine possible by the
way there are two D's in atoms if you're going to
gossip about me at least spell my name correctly
turn that off this is your final warning oh
hey you aware cat evening girls oh sorry about
the mud wanted to make sure it was settling in
if you're serious regular I guess it's cool Tim
Burton brings her back she played Wednesday that's
cool I want to go over a few house rules lights
off at 10 no loud music and no boys ever yeah okay
that's really cool they got her on
the show yeah that's really cool
oh my God she's got Action Hero skills doesn't
she she's gonna do several backflips maybe if
you whined Less in practice more you wouldn't
suck seriously coach when am I gonna get some
real competition right now you must be the
psychopath they let in and you must be the
self-appointed queen bee interesting thing about
bees pull out their stingers and they drop dead
let's go kill her decapitate her
Wednesday become your mother [Music]
oh man I love a good fencing scene
point to Wednesday ouch I wonder how many times
this was actually Jenna Ortega Corey's even
made her mad now for the final point I would like
to invoke a military challenge no masks no tips
winner draws First Blood let's
do it don't be a coward Bianca
nice get her oh dang oh wowie
oh [__] no one makes me bleed my
own blood your face finally got that
splash of color it's so desperately needed yikes
so like General Ortega is like perfect
she really is she just like has this gravitational
pull on the whole screen sorry about that
Nick no good deed goes unpunished Danny
Elfman had fun scoring this show every
scene has so much music I know that's got
to be like an auxiliary character foreign
the umbrella too
art guy tortured artist torture an
artist guy of course welcome back
if it makes you feel any better let's just say I
returned the favor it was my Godmother's funeral
apparently she was friends with your
grandmother and they spent their 20s
together in Europe swindling the rich and
notorious cool decided to play hide and seek
I had the inspired idea to hide in her casket
headed to the crematorium I had heard muffled
screams I just figured your godmother had
somehow cheated death and was trying to claw
her way out either way you hit the big red stop
button and save me from being flame broiled so
now we're even oh could have both had an
imaginative death I knew it hello thing
did you really think my highly trained
old factory sense wouldn't pick up on the
Fate whiff of Neroli and Bergamot
in your favorite hand lotion oh
mother and father sent you to spy on
me didn't they you have two options
[__] you in here for the rest of the semester
when you go slowly insane trying to claw your
way out two you pled your own dying loyalty to me
do it do it things bend the knee I wonder who who
they hire to play thing because they're doing
a great job on emoting so much through that one
hand I want to know what that audition was like
yeah you got to do a lot you feel like there's
a face there well I'm doing like sign language
in that position too like it's a cool addition
name for chocolate principal Williams this feeble
attempt at bonding is Beneath You Miller and go
hey yeah I hope we can forge a relationship based
on trust you are not the right therapist for her
my personal philosophy is killer be killed
so for instance when someone bullies your
brother your response is to dump piranha in
the pool you know the old saying never bring
a knife to a sword fight unless it's concealed
I have no remorse for your actions that's why
you're here he lost a testicle I did the world
a favor people like Dalton shouldn't be allowed
to procreate I've answered all your questions
we're not done yet oh interesting you might be
the right therapist editors are short-sighted
fear-based life forms one wants to square my
writing as gratuitously morbid and suggested I
seek psychiatric help hence I sent her a thank you
[Music]
would you mind if I use the powder room first
okay is everything okay I think Tim Burton did
a great job with this pilot yeah
it's restrained but still stylish
you have to find the right tone where you
don't get two inch respective of our ruins
The Morbid fun it's literally playing
cat and mouse with emotional development
yes put those creepers to work
[Music]
you got that weirdo let him die that reminds
me of that Christopher Walken sketch from SNL
I mean spoiler alert for your special machines
having a seizure so all we have is Drew a truck
is for people who hate themselves and know
their lives have no real purpose or meaning
it's gonna leave that here
I'm Tyler by the way I didn't catch your name
or is that on a need to know basis too Wednesday
do not hate you I could Burling to myself
perfect I don't get off for another hour
you do now I can't be bought so either
wait or find someone else to drive you so
much respect Tyler you'd be good for her [Music]
oh great pilgrims eat me what's the never more
freak going out in the wild this is our booth
why are you three just like religious fanatics
pilgrims potato potato we work at Pilgrim
world oh girl world it takes a special kind
of stupid to devote an entire theme park
to zealots responsible for Mass genocide
have you ever been on the Normie I've never
found one that could handle me
she's got them comebacks dude
what's up
big wide swings so where do
you learn those Kung Fu moves
my uncle taught me we spent five years
in the Tibetan monastery Monk prisoner
polish Sheriff this one's slipped away
from me come on Miss Adams time to go
you're in Adams oh no tell me Gomez Adams is your
father that man belongs Behind Bars from murder
guessing the Apple doesn't fall far from
the tree I'm gonna keep my eye on you okay
the challenge accepted she always
picks the rights moments a smile
gross Wowie [Music]
let's go Apocalyptica [Music]
oh I like this dude she actually
learned how to work the neck
[Music]
Tom Riddle he's like the combination of Tom Riddle
and uh David crumb holds from
Adam's Family Values foreign
[Music]
I guess so maybe Gomez killed his
wife awesome [Music] right [Music]
foreign
no I don't really feel better where's the rest of
him it's one of the great Adams Family Mysteries
now we need a whole origin series spin-off
why aren't you wolfing out because I can't
I've been to the best like an ologist had
to play to Milwaukee would you believe it
yeah she says there's a chance I might never
my life would be officially over my feather
always framed like it yeah why are you crying
because I'm upset haven't you ever cried are
you above that too I cried once on top of a
mountain tears of joy after murdering someone
I was six years old I took my pet scorpion Nero
out for his afternoon stroll when we were ambushed
I have a nice cream they wondered what kind
of freak would have a scorpion for a pet oh
two of them held me down and made
me watch oh no buddy front Nero
oh that is cruel must be a core memory
cried my little black heart out [Music]
that is a really cool Tombstone
with the Black Dahlia to top it off
your secret's safe with me I still think you're
weird as [__] though the feeling is incredibly
Mutual they have really good chemistry yeah they
don't sound like they're reading lines together no
sound like just an actual scene a couple of other
actors I wouldn't say the same yeah okay oh [__]
I harm one hair on things Palm
reverse Palm this isn't weird at all
cool you should have led with that yeah just
High roll over that's thing you see like your pit
there's the Harvest Festival this weekend
attendance is mandatory if you're still willing
to drive me to the train station I can make it
worth your while considered a freebie why at
least one of us will get out of this hellhole town
stand up to your dad doesn't exactly feel 100 like
old Tim Bergen but like big fish Timber you know
a little bit around that time was Tim Burton's
career big eyes big fish still better than like
99 of things Tim Burton does today yeah I'll
take this yeah or whatever else I haven't seen
Riverdale but this gives me Vibes of what I've
heard about Riverdale yeah but Sabrina probably
has some yeah thematic tissue with this get any
better at this you'll be taking home a whole
pack pandas don't travel in packs they prefer
the Solitude subtle hint taken I'm gonna stick
around you see that sad lonely woman over there
would you mind distracting her girl you got
money despair I know it's your side hustle
Wednesday it's your dad's police file for me was
it Nevermore not used to people engaging with me
coming across the street scary you just
kinda spooky and mysterious and spooky
and altogether ookie that's a Jesus Christ
Resurrection act we can lose them in the crowd
I think Wednesday could take them on oh no
[Music] oh girl you're gonna need to stay
behind face The Raven face the raven come back
how many guy friends has went there how many
pales from what blonde white guy friends
who all look like leads in various
Tim Burton movies what do you want
why are you following me I don't have time to
explain but you're in danger you're gonna end
up like the lanky guy from stranger things I
think you've got it backwards I am the danger
the gargoyle that was you
girl in the picture that's you
oh put me down no my mother said it was my
destiny to stop this girl if she ever came to
Nevermore because she will destroy the school and
everyone in it wow you need more evidence [Music]
foreign
there's a mislead
golly Let Yourself Go the eyes look like
that truck driver but I'm wondering if
it's the cop's son no torture artist The Mysteries
that I could potentially destroy the
school and was mysteriously saved
by a homicidal monster I think I'm
going to love it here laughs [Music]
Kudos nice the story is about to take a dark turn
again are we supposed to wash us I don't feel like
it's necessary yeah I'm gonna stop this just in
case yeah we're gonna watch it I don't know if
that was like something shot just for this as
a joke but uh see if you can yell at us in the
comments if we're supposed to be watching yeah
all right let's talk about that's great that was
really well done that was a really really well
done well this is one of those Netflix reactions
so you know what that means that the review part
of this we will attempt to keep it short because
there's uh really no point most you guys already
know what how the show ends and you're really
much let's just move on to the next one next
episode we'll talk about it a little bit I think
a pilot deserves it I thought this was a really
solid pilot I think that would I mean I was really
drawn to the fact that Tim Burton I didn't know
he directed it I thought I heard his name was
attached but I didn't know he was someone who
actually held any of the episodes so to uh it gave
me a different kind of observant eye because I'm
uh I haven't watched some of his later films I I
have seen some of later films but you know some of
his earlier workers some of my favorite films
of all time sure and it was cool to see some
more of that Tim Burton Flair uh come back and
I think what they're doing here with setting up
a because it doesn't like while there's the winks
and nods to Adam's Family it doesn't feel reliant
on it like I think you can watch this without
having had any awareness of Adam's Family while
there's elements that play on a certain element of
nostalgia and certain Winks it doesn't feel like
it's necessary to be aware of Adam's Family to
enjoy it because even with its like Macabre tone
I think the way how Tim Burton struck a certain
specific kind of tone with its narrative because
they're doing something where you are doing a bit
more of an introspective look at Wednesday Adams
and putting her into more of a modern day world
obviously because we're talking about social media
and all that [__] so it takes place in modern
day and yet it still has an old-school Flair to it
while simultaneously doing a lot more of this
type of morbid Macabre sensibility it's not
it's it doesn't I when it's when they
introduce like the therapy segment
sometimes a thing can get like kind of um divided
in itself the project can get divided of like what
what exactly kind of energy or story are we trying
to tell and it doesn't try to go too realistic on
Wednesday atoms which you can't really do but
you can do just enough to kind of understand
or like you get her traumatic backstory with her
pet scorpion and uh examining some parts of her
upbringing that she does feel resentful towards
and I like this uh Journey that they they set
up with her and needless to say Jenna Ortega is
uh as as anything you see general or take it she
again is right spot she's perfect she's she's
absolutely perfect in this role I I can see her
becoming and maybe she is for some people already
the definitive Wednesday atoms and I think that's
pretty neat to have Christina Ritchie in here too
uh as some as the person who's like done works
with Tim Burton in the past some of his best work
and some of her best work and of course being once
they added it was it two films there's two films
yeah yeah both the Barry sonenfeld films yeah yeah
so that's pretty cool to have her return there's a
lot I really liked about it there are some little
qualms that I don't feel like overshadow my
experience that I'll go into uh but for now
this is my positives there's more to positively
highlight like music and [__] but want a thin
one hump frontin this what did you think good sir
Ramble On yeah Ramble On I like this I like this
as a pilot a new pilots can be kind of you know
tricky but I thought this nailed itself down as
a nice kind of well proportioned piece and yes uh
as somebody who too has a lot of love for various
Tim Burton joints and a lot of wariness for where
his career is currently at I kind of got what you
meant when you said part way through the episode
like it it doesn't feel like the most Tim Burton
it could possibly be it doesn't feel like this
is a full-on Tim Burton movie iteration of what
an atoms family world would look like however I
feel like this is kind of the right environment
for him because you know with the budgets of these
kinds of series you don't have you you can get to
the point where you have huge effects budgets
but clearly right now this show isn't relying
on those and so I feel like there's enough kind
of restriction to keep Tim Burton in the tangible
where I think he works arguably the best some
of the time and this is a series I think we'll
probably have at least a few other directors in
the mix and so there's also that element of like
yeah I feel like even if he is a huge guiding
creative voice on this it won't just be the Tim
Burton show and and yeah while parts of me are
like oh man go even further I'm also happy to
see that yeah right now they're taking their time
to gradually set this up and to find the tone and
balance between being just comic strip enough but
not too comic strip like you pointed out and so
coming into this I had reasons to be wary just
because this is a Wednesday Adams and The Adams
Family are characters that lend themselves to this
kind of thing but this is also very Here and Now
take where it is very Riverdale very Sabrina
very sort of like okay we're gonna make her some
kind of mystery solver we're gonna put her at the
core of a lot of converging storytelling factors
that are very popular to right now and it could go
either way and right now at least I feel like it's
going in a in a direction that I'm happy to keep
following and that doesn't you know give me at
least right now it's not ringing the wariness bell
of like oh here we go you know like I'm actually
happy to see Wednesday grow uh in herself as
well as you know kind of confronting her ability
to interface with other people and I've heard
people say that Wednesday is sort of coded in
a sort of autistic kind of way not to not to you
know be insensitive but to actually just be like
that's kind of how they are portraying uh just the
way she experiences the world as a character and
I think that's kind of a neat and interesting
undertone and that kind of helps actually to
inform the stuff that's real the stuff about being
an outcast and the stuff about being misunderstood
for just how you engage with the world and I
feel like that is stuff that for a Wednesday
Adam's like character you can Shine the light
on and expound upon and make interesting while
also not dispelling the Mystique of the character
and it was like a great choice where they're like
how did thing become what he is and they're like
I don't know it's one of the great Adams Family
Mysteries I was like good it seems like they
have a good grip on where to flesh out versus
where to keep the mystery and keep the comic strip
slightness that yeah then goes to sell the sort of
Rye sardonic nature of this whole universe in
general so yeah I think they they did The Fish
Out of Water nicely but they also gave you a
big fish yay big fish out of Lady in the Water
is a shyam lines it's not like a Tim Burton water
pun is there I'll get there someday Planet of the
Apes all of us men folk haha um but yeah yeah I'm
excited to see where this goes I I would I'm glad
we saw the rest of the Adams family here and if
we're gonna see anybody the most I'm glad it's
thing I would kind of like to see the rest of the
family too or like stop by the Adam's house just
to feel like because this is its own new universe
ostensibly so you know I would like to by the
end of this get a whole sense for what The Adams
Family life is like yeah I think the environment's
really good here though we're we're setting at
this Nevermore High School uh very Hogwarts meets
Xavier's School for the gifted yeah it's it's a
cool it's a cool layer and I like the I like the
Aesthetics a lot of what they've brought to life
I think they've and really nailed that down and
there's a good blend of practical ncgi I mean the
Tim Burton of today is gonna be very annoying with
the CGI because that's like you have consistently
pointed out over the years of how uh you know cgis
become like the death for Tim Burton in a lot of
ways and I I appreciated that it seemed like they
there are times where I'm like okay it took me
a while to tell that was CGI but a lot of times
seems like they only really used it when they
needed to sure and even at times when it looks
a little wonky it doesn't bother me because
it's part of the spirit and the like like the
werewolf at the end looks like really it's not the
greatest CGI but it doesn't bother me because as
long as the emotionality and the engagement with
the scene is still happening then that's all that
really counts I'm gonna make Goosebumps yeah
no there's a there the part that made me go 90
like in the beginning it starts off like 80s high
school movie but the parts that make me feel like
a 90s movie which I guess is appropriate for the
is Adam Sandler movies or 90s right yeah I think
they're early early 90s yeah it was when uh the
Gwendolyn Christie pulls up in the family van like
I haven't seen that van since like the 90s yeah
yeah that's when I had that um awareness of it and
yeah I mean like the the roommate and her I feel
like have a amazing chemistry I think it's really
good and I could see already the Inception of
that how that's going to evolve over time because
there's other scenes that especially when it comes
to Pilots where I can hear the the actor reading
together I could hear a bit of the audition sides
as they call them when you audition and not that
like everyone here I thought actually did a really
good job it was just certain like chemistry read
scenes like with the the first scene with um the
self-tortured artist I don't want this to sound
like I I didn't like that like I appreciate all
the context and I think they both did a good job
with that that did have a a sound to it that was
like yeah it sounds like actors are like reading
together and and then also the uh the the guy in
the coffee shop Tyler Tyler but I still like them
though I don't want that to sound like I still
like them you know uh but there are times where
kind of pull me out and I do think there was like
this is like Danny this is like pure Danny elf
score and I love that I love that like it's Danny
elfman's score with Tim Burton it's just awesome
to hear that I love most of the music there were
times rarely out of an hour-long episode but there
were times where I'm like you can kind of lower
the volume a little bit we get it guys because
sometimes when they didn't have music I was like I
was more pulled into the scene yeah and sometimes
it becomes a little overwhelming yeah and most
people probably aren't watching this headphones
like we are yeah so over to watch it with like
headphones I really get the surround sound like
there is so much like the music does not stop
um that being said I'd rather have the music
than not have the music like I said when I said
qualms there I would say they were like little
I'm sure to some people there are not bothersome
whatsoever but it does have that classical Gothic
Danny Elfman tune that you'd want when you're
hearing the adaptation of Wednesday Adams it
almost feels like like from behind the camera you
can feel the enthusiasm so as the viewer you're
like okay okay pull it back a little bit I'm happy
you're here I'm happy you're here I'm happy you're
doing your thing pull it back over here yeah
restrain it a little bit because because that's
kind of the nice surprise here is that while there
are elements in which I would love to see them go
incredibly Bonkers I do appreciate that for this
pilot you know it's restrained in the right ways
sure yeah and uh and two like you said I think
there is I'll be interested to see how everybody
acclimates to the dialogue because this is one of
those shows that I think also has a Razor's Edge
to walk on when it comes to that kind of writing
because dialogue has to be stylized and you've
got to have everybody able to deliver it without
it sounding too precocious or pretentious or like
ah you think that your dialogue is super Snappy
and all that stuff and and I've I've heard not
really specifics but I've heard uh tell of Jenna
Ortega kind of throwing things out for takes and
things like that and a lot of those takes being
the ones that made it to the final product and
so it seems like an exciting opportunity Unity
for you know one of those uh you know sort of
lightning in a bottle casting moments where yeah
somebody becomes like the custodian of a character
and like really infuses it with their own you
know sort of life and enthusiasm and and yeah
like I'm just excited to see how it builds and
it's like all the elements are here nothing is
is too out of whack to the point where I think
it will you know drop off or or you know fall in
a Hole uh but there's still like little bits of
room for improvement obviously like I'm really I
want to see Uncle Fester at some point I feel like
that's the thing I'm looking forward to the most
um so Fred armisen's plan yes yeah I believe so
that was see he appears like once in the trailer
I think so okay yeah so that was that was big
excitement for me like and I like the casting
of the rest of the atoms I I really liked Pugsley
a lot for his like brief inclusion I want to see
more of Louise Guzman and Catherine Zeta Jones
together because I I appreciate what the scenes
necessitate them doing but I also want to see them
in like full full form sure yeah I'm not I don't
really uh like they're fine mostly I'm okay with
waiting for yeah I'm not itching but I mean you
have more of a well built-in love oh yeah I guess
maybe the the thing to to Circle back around what
you said earlier like that's the one thing that
I think you will benefit like you can I think
watch this with no prior knowledge and this will
probably be the Gateway for a lot of people into
atoms anything but as yeah if you've seen the old
stuff it kind of relies on you understanding those
basic principles because they're not going to use
more tissue or Gomez or Pugsley very much or Lurch
or any of that you know like I don't know if any
other auxiliary characters like Grandma or cousin
it or anything come into play but yeah like they
with those bits and pieces when they're driving to
the school I thought they were first gonna drive
like to the Adam's house just to establish that
and they you know they don't they don't have to
but that's something that does rely on sort of
like okay either you'll catch up later or you
just kind of know and and that's not what we're
trying to do here so we're gonna brush past that
stuff but I don't think anybody would be lost or
anything like that yeah yeah you get once you
get Wednesday and you see what family she comes
from you understand the the gag of the atoms
yeah yeah and and I did I do think the Comedy
Works and I think the writing and I don't know
what lines Jenna ortegos the ones that she came
up with and the writers came up with but I think
there's a there's a great type of witty comeback
to how she delivers those lines and the way
they're written too yeah that always sound um
like that is how what this character of Wednesday
how she would frame like something as little as
um oh what does she say about the pilgrim shoe
the buckle buckle show if the buckled Shoe Fits
yeah yeah so the same if the shoe fits she says
if the buckled shoe fits you know it's just a
little extra salt on there oh yeah I think she's
yeah every comeback she's always she's always very
cool as she needs to be yeah and it never fails
her there and that's that's good yeah and and of
course uh yeah that with with thing I think the
uh effects of thing are phenomenal terminal and
yeah the way because it's always been like a great
gimmick of thing but it's never felt more alive
like you really feel like a personality that's
that's got to be a real hand I'm no yeah totally
yeah so it made it does make me wonder like how
they film certain parts sure um sure especially
when there are when it's less of like when it's
just like a shot on thing you're like okay I can
see what probably happened here but yeah when in
the more complex shots yeah I'd be curious to know
if like how many scenes were it like there must
have been certain shots where they allowed Jenna
Ortega to interact with the real hand yeah like
he was just there and she had to like zone out the
green yeah not think about the dude in the blue
body sock just to talk to the hand or literally
talk to the hand and I think I think the way his
there was so much expression yeah and I was I was
surprised like like both thing and Jenna Ortega
they they have that instant I know this character
yeah yes yeah and not because I know Adam I
don't know Adam's family that well I really don't
um there's a very deep complex lore you're missing
like I've seen the movie saying like I didn't even
watch the sequel you know so there's a reaction
and it didn't grow up family values go watch that
I've seen like passing episodes of as I I didn't
grow up cartoons yeah and not the cartoons um was
there cartoons weren't there cartoons where's
the cartoons I feel like there are cartoons I
mean there's certainly like comic strips there
was the black and white old TV show yeah yeah
the movies there's the animated movie they made
recently yeah yeah yeah so I'm not that familiar
um but like this interpretation I really got
uh but I like the Mysteries they have a foot
as well and I think the supernatural angle is a
is an intriguing one very modern day yeah she's
got those Visions you got those Christopher
Walken Visions it's not part of it right uh
not my Recollections Family original Edition okay
no because I mean yeah like the if we're going way
back like it's a lot more innocuous than that um
and it's just yeah mostly that fish out of water
quality and then in the movies with like Christina
Ricci is Wednesday Adams I don't I don't remember
there being any distinct telekinetic thing they
just they just kind of exist outside the the realm
of normal physics yeah you know but yeah this is
I think this is a contrivance for this show the
whole death Visions oh yeah she's finds the right
Spirit to channel here Jenna Ortega because this
easily could have been very one note in caricature
it could and she manages to she's always listening
she's always processing yeah that's the great part
while being a you know that that's dry delivery
kind of character she's still finds just the right
Shades to express or emote a tiny bit more to clue
Us in and there's always more going on behind
the eyes uh than just like don't blink and stare
there's always so much more happening there's more
soul to her and I think that's a great touch so
yeah guys uh solo first start for Wednesday we'll
see how the rest of the episodes go the only thing
I've heard is there's like a dance scene that
is the meme that's the main thing I've heard I I
haven't seen a moment of it so yeah yeah I've seen
if anything I've seen the classic of the little
girls like black and white doing the dance but I
don't know if it's the same dance yeah but it's
it's reminiscent at least that's all I've heard
is there's some dancing so we'll have to limber
up for that episode whenever that happens yeah
we'll see how that goes alrighty guys well what
do you think about our reaction should we react
differently yeah do we have to do it is this a
little a little bit of change here subscribe
leave a like and listen us with a patreon
James the Smith Smith you got that Gothic spelling
on your name I like it it's like old timey
like a Wednesday Adams mystery story plot
I hope you're feeling well here at the end of
the year I hope you are feeling colorful and
optimistic unless you know unless you're that
kind of person unless you like a dreary day a
monochrome maybe that's what makes you happy I
hope you're able to enjoy that as well either
way thanks for sticking on our patreon thanks
for you know believing in the freaks of the
reject nation and not rejecting us for our outward
appearances but for our inward qualities you're a
good dude James Smith and I hope you're having
a a merry holiday season and a Happy New Year
that was surprisingly normal ah because you
know I pulled the normals out for the weird
shows man that's how I like to create irony
I embrace myself for a roller coaster and
then here we are like oh wow that was it we
didn't know drops no Loops subversions G yeah
that's one hell of a subversion there's a why in
Wednesday James Smith which means at the heart of
your last name is the end of Wednesday's
name which makes you the thing of them
[Music]